this is a Fox News Alert three strikes
and Biden's proxies are out moments ago
a Colorado judge ruled that Donald Trump
is staying on the 2024 ballot in that
state remember the Fourth Amendment
challenge that was lodged in Colorado in
Min Minnesota and in Michigan all three
of those have gone Trump's way joining
me now is Mike Davis founder in
president of the article 3 project and a
former clerk to Supreme Court Justice
Neil Gorsuch Mike your reaction these
are three rulings now that have tossed
aside at least now for now the 14th
Amendment um argument that the left was
saying was their ticket to keeping Trump
off the ballot tell us what this
means well I think this this bias Denver
District Court Judge out here blinks
because I was certain sitting through
the trial the weekl long trial that she
was going to rule against President
Trump and I think that she saw the
political back lash and she saw that
three other courts uh in three different
states ruled against this Democrat
Theory to try to toss president Trump
off the ballot they impeached him twice
indicted him four times two illegal gag
orders tried to bankrupt him with a
bogus civil fraud lawsuit that only
helped president Trump with the polls
and this was their legal Hail Mary to
just take Trump off the ballot and now
they're 0 for
three so this is District Judge Sarah
Wallace and it's a third ruling as I
said in just a little over a week and
these these lawsuits were filed um by a
left-leaning group that included a bunch
of you know never trumpers Democrats and
so forth but here's a key quote from the
judge's ruling she said to be clear part
of the Court's decision is its
reluctance to embrace an interpretation
which would disqualify a presidential
candidate without a clear unmistakable
indication that such is the intent of
section three the section three of the
con section three I believe in the
Constitutional argument of the 14th
Amendment is that correct
Mike that is correct and this judge came
back from the brink because we could not
get anything worse for our country to
Simply take the leading presidential
candidate off the ballot based upon a
bogus partisan legal theory that the
Democrats are pedaling here the only way
to disqualify a an office holder under
SE three of the Constitution according
to case law that's that's been on the
books for over 150 years is to bring
Federal criminal charges for
Insurrection or Rebellion have a jury
unanimously find them guilty with
evidence Beyond a reasonable doubt that
the district judge has to convict and
that conviction has to be upheld on
appeal that's the only route and there's
no chance that that President Trump was
involved with an Insurrection on January
6 it was a lawful protest permitted by
the National Park Service that got out
of control and turned into a right now
everyone should understand so the
Minnesota Supreme Court ruling on this
was that was just last week again said
that Trump could remain on the primary
ballot because political parties have
the sole Choice over whether he appears
and then the Michigan judge who ruled on
this um said that Congress is the proper
forum for deciding whether section three
of the 14th amendment applies so three
different judges three different parts
of the country and Mike I now want to
bring in an attorney who defended Trump
in this former Colorado Secretary of
State Scott Gessler I mean Scott I think
it it was so ironic that all of these
individuals who are out there calling
Trump a force against democracy this is
dangerous tyrannical impulses of Donald
Trump yet this is precisely what this
radical interpretation of of section
three article um of uh of the 14th
Amendment excuse me the Constitution
would have done by ripping him off the
ballot it's stunning to me yeah that's
exactly the case um unfortunately this
judge allowed them to uh go through a
full five-day hearing and a lot further
in the process than this should have
ever gone but um but ultimately she made
the right decision and that decision is
that the people of the United States
we're the ones who get to choose uh who
our president is going to be not the
courts and uh and it's about I mean the
whole uh this whole series of cases I
mean it relies on some pretty unusual
theories from a law that hasn't been
enforced for probably over a hundred
years uh so it's a it was a desperate
attempt to really prevent people from
being able to vote for the person they
want and Mike I've said this time and
again it's worth repeating tonight is
that the only way the left will stop if
they're stopped if they're stopped by
either being you know a judge's ruling
and it has to be an emphatic ruling or a
sweeping elect Toral Victory by
Americans who just say you know enough
of this this is this isn't even Common
Sense forget being a constitutional
scholar this makes no sense but you know
judges one after the other have come in
and said cannot do
this yeah I mean I would say this is
going to be a tactical retreat by the
Democrats like you said Laura they will
they play for keeps they will do
whatever it takes to win if you thought
that 2020 was bad with BLM RS brace
ourselves for what they have in store in
2024 with their Hamas and M
supports and when we look at this the
way this was case is is being argued and
look they're going to not stop so you
know you argue this case and you win in
Colorado but what's the next Hill that
has to be climbed for president Trump
it's the former um state
Secretary well from a legal standpoint I
think Colorado was probably their best
chance uh I don't I think this is their
high water mark I'm sure they'll try
appealing it to to the Colorado Supreme
Court but I don't think they'll have any
more luck there than they've had
anywhere else across the country so I'm
guessing they'll probably start cooking
up a new legal Theory uh that we haven't
no one's thought of yet because it's so
far out to the left wing that no one
will think of it but uh this I think is
I hope is their High
Watermark Scott were you surprised if
you saw it in this new um I believe this
was the M no sorry this was the yeah
this is the Washington Post on Monmouth
poll that shows that Republican primary
voters in New Hampshire the third I
think it's the third most important
issue for them is the Justice
Department's um unfair application of
the law that that's it was a it was the
open border it was inflation high prices
and I think that came in either third or
fourth ahead of crime what does that
tell you about what Republican primary
voters are seeing and that's in again
the quirky State of New Hampshire yeah I
I think people are really concerned
about fundamental fairness in this
country and and you know we even saw
this in Colorado where the Secretary of
State the current Secretary of State
here instead of sort of being neutral
and an honest broker as soon as this
complaint was filed she came out and
accused president Trump of all kinds of
things and it was pretty clear she was
biased from the start so I think people
are really concerned about the
weaponization of the Department of
Justice of a lot of our public officials
you know particularly ones who uh you
know just hate president Trump they want
to do everything they can to stop them
and they're using the law rather than
the Democratic
processes and Mike nothing is worse than
that judge anger and I I just think that
that case in New York the law clerk the
judge the smirking for the camera
Leticia James of all the cases do you
think that is perhaps the worst and the
most obviously biased
Mike that I mean they're blatantly
biased but the problem is is he's
clearly going to rule against Trump and
try to bankrupt his business thank God
we have people like aise stonic or
Congressional lead filed an Ethics
complaint against this biased Manhattan
judge and we need to start fighting back
against this laware and election
interference Scott and Mike both of you
thank you so much hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else